you need to dream big i mean you cannot
dream big enough i'm telling you you
can't dream big enough you can do more
than you're doing but you can't do more
than you're doing if you hang around
with little thinkers that could be your
family members could be your friends
could be people you're going to school
with and hanging out with look there's a
time and a place to hang out with those
people can't pick your family i mean to
say you can't i wonder sometimes we
don't actually do the picking and just
show up there without say that for
another conversation but i do know once
once you get with your family the family
that you picked or they picked or
however that might work in the selection
process wherever you went to school or
go to school or where you grew up or how
you grew up or the religion you grew up
in or whether you're white or black or
brown male or female question's always
going to be what can you do to do more
with your life to find your mission to
find your purpose to find what you're
great at to get great at the things
maybe that you're not great at that you
don't even like doing number one think
big telling you can do more and you will
do more than you ever imagined if you're
ever successful in your life if you ever
hit it and you can you will look back 10
15 20 years from now say god what was i
thinking what was i thinking i promise
you you know it's like 80 pounds of
weight looks like a lot when you're five
or six years old later pretty easy to
pick that up no matter what your frame
is as long as you do the work as long as
you do the work and show up in the gym
one day you'll better pick that barbell
up just like in life okay the things
that you think are impossible today the
things that you hate today things that
you aren't good at the things that you
think are a waste of time the things
that make you angry are all
opportunities for you need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation hey
it's evan carmichael and i make these
videos because chances are you are the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of more and you
get that push by surrounding yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best grant cardone and my
take on his top 10 rules for success
enjoy
rule number two get your money right and
the first thing to becoming a
millionaire a multi-millionaire a hectic
millionaire or a billionaire
and i've spent time with enough
billionaires now
is they have made decisions to get their
money right okay whether they're going
public or selling a product scaling out
they had to make a decision to get the
money the finance model of their
household their business their product
or their ipo right right if they want to
go to the market and become a public
company so number one get your money
right
it's not about product knowledge first
it's not about sales knowledge first
it's not about sales process first it's
not about the follow-up first or writing
the customer up first it's not even
about attitude first it's about get your
financial mental get your money mental
right okay because if you're satisfied
if you're happy where you are
financially why would you sell anything
else look let's face it you're on
commission you get paid to sell things
you get paid to close deals you get paid
to follow up
only when it works
okay number one get your money mindset
right rule number three initiate the
objective anybody ever surf you ever got
covered up by wave
and it's throwing you down and you're
like
and you're like i can't wait to come up
and as soon as you come up you're like
oh my god damn bam another one hit you
okay this is a tsunami
this is a tsunami there is no place you
can go and escape what's going on here
you can go get another job we have many
people that have tried that already some
of you might be thinking about it you're
going to go some other place and you're
going to meet yourself again
and the tsunami will be wherever you go
there is no getting away from the
tsunami the only way out of this deal is
to say hey what do i have to sell
today
okay so right now right now dave did a
deal yesterday 9.95
what kind of business was it dave solar
60 months
did you ask the guy are you going to be
in business in 2025 yeah
what do you say well he it was a
three-year deal he didn't like the price
they said okay let's do five let's do
five years yeah good okay so so you guys
need to start asking people first of all
are you going to be in business next
year
you need to ask every person you need to
include a couple of words in in in your
pitch right now okay
hey are you going bankrupt
you need to ask them are you going to go
bankrupt because they're thinking about
it trust me
they are thinking about i'm going to
bust out here you need to bring it up
before they do this is straight out of
seller be sold initiate the objective of
the objection
the unspoken objection is what's going
to kill your deals rule number four
decide to turn around from 15 to 25 i
was using drugs every day
so when i tell you
hey you can do anything
i was a
habitual
daily drug user
overdosed three times
was brought back by people just
wandering into a room saying oh this
guy's in trouble okay i was i don't know
if i was trying to kill myself at the
time or i was just didn't know what i
was doing or stupid or whatever like
i was a walking time bomb
and i was not to be trusted by my family
by my friends there was no one in my
life between 15 and 25 that i could have
a positive influence on
i was a liability
to everyone in my life including my
family
and my friends and people i went to
school with and the places i worked at i
lost seven jobs in a row i was
unemployable
25 i went to a treatment center and said
i got to turn this around
i got to turn this around i cannot keep
using drugs they're bad for me i make
poor decisions when i'm using them
i i i go out with the wrong people hang
with the wrong people end up in the
wrong fights i literally got like when
you're using drugs you're going to pick
fights you can't win not in a lifetime
you're going to get in the wrong cars
make the wrong decisions the wrong
purchases
and you're going to miss a lot of great
opportunities
so first thing is
you can't do great things
if you're incapable of making great
decisions
and when you're
under the influence
and i don't want to preach to you i'm
just telling you what what advice i'd
give myself if i was on the comeback and
i was
15 years old and being influenced by
everybody smoking the kush
it's cool now
it's probably going to be legal
everywhere
going out drinking on the weekends
forgetting everything that you did
and just making poor decisions so i tell
you hey you got you got to figure out
how how is that going to somehow
advance your life you're going to have
to make some hard choices if i'm a young
guy coming up young gal coming up how
can i pick great relationships when
everybody's under the influence
and again i don't mean to sound like a
like a
a preacher or anything because i'm
definitely not that we're going to have
a great time this weekend
i'm here for a week we're gonna have a
lot of fun
but i couldn't do that if i was still
under the influence every day
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five get rid of average
mentality first get rid of the little
think
and the old ideas
and the middle class
[Music]
mentality gonna go to work i'm gonna
save some money i'm gonna put it in the
bank i'm gonna give it to the man
what's the bank dude the bank doesn't
even keep your money
they hate money
cash is
it's trash
cashes garbage is pieces of garbage
paper
it is only useful when it is used if
you're taking notes
they didn't teach you this in school
this should have been taught basic
fifth grade sixth grade not in not when
in high school or college
cash this is a piece of paper okay it is
a piece of paper it's worthless this is
a piece of paper
this actually has more value this piece
of paper right here has more value than
this piece of paper right here why
because one person has this piece of
paper
2 000 people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
rule number six restart you failed the
business no problem
you restart another business
so the way to play this is let's go
ahead and give your business the best
shot
you need training you're going to need
sales you're going to need phone skills
you're going to need follow-up otherwise
it's going to fail okay now watch we put
it on a credit card
if we put it on a credit card and you
fail
the bankruptcy court picks up the visa
mastercard the american express
the training contract you you you did
with us lives on for your next company
you guys understand that
100 of those people
will continue on in some other business
a few of them will commit suicide
okay oh i'm done
but the rest of them are going to be
like i gotta go do something and they
are going to restructure and start
another company donald trump has
restructured casinos man this is not a
new thing like the big boys restructure
okay
fail boom we restructure we'll create
something new i still got a business
okay you got to get this guy to see this
might fail but you won't because you
won't quit and you're going to be over
here rule number seven eliminate
distraction in people's lives
you have distractions
and you have opportunities to go do
other stuff and look at other stuff
[Applause]
you know it's like in indecisi
indecisiveness
is the weakness
as you wear so well
and it's like look you guys want to be
you want to be hoodwinked by the covid
you want to be hijacked by the election
you want to be uh thrown off because of
somebody's uh
comments about you
like the the universe will send you
endless
numbers of distractions
and and to to people that are fully
completely committed
they're like yeah i saw that happen yeah
i heard there was a car wreck over there
guys sent me something this morning uh
on from fox news
about this guy that was arrested i'm
like why are you passing this on to me
and i said do not never pass on bad
information to me i don't need it i
don't want it i'm not interested in it
by the way you're better than that and
all the people you know
the people you know don't need that
message
and at the same time by the way he sent
it to a friend of mine another friend of
mine my wife got it but nobody said stop
it
hey guys hey guys
papa's on a podcast
sorry about that
so again you see that like like stop the
distraction stop the noise and and if
you don't say no to it it will continue
uh it will feed you
to be distracted and give you excuses to
not achieve the things that you're
capable of rule number eight pay the
price today
learn to discipline yourself
if you've got to go to the gym every day
if you hate going to the gym go to the
gym i don't like going to the gym but
i'm like i don't like my body hurting
either sooner or later if you don't go
to the gym and work your body your body
will
it will scream at you and it will hurt
lower back pains arms shoulders knees
you name it it's always going to hurt
and as long as it's hurting how can you
be fully available for the people around
you if your body's certain two you gotta
eat good foods okay gotta make decisions
i ain't gonna eat junk
i'm not gonna eat the junk why why
because i'm saying no to junk
if you can start saying no to stuff
you can start saying yes to the good
things like my little girl right there
sabrina say hi sabrina
so pay the price today learn how to be
great at jobs you hate
that's paying the price get up early
go to bed early okay beat the sun up
every morning it'll give you so much
confidence i'm paying the price when i
do that when i get up before the sun
gets up i'm paying the price when i go
to bed at nine o'clock and i'm not
watching tv and movies and just being
entertained and effective whatever's
coming my way i'm paying the price
when i don't waste the weekends the
weekends make you weak listen to me
weekends are for weak people
anything after 10 o'clock at night it's
for weak people
okay saturday and sunday staying up all
night week people people are made weak
on the weekends
pay the price okay give up the weekends
for the next
five years
and watch what happens five years man
that's a lot of weekends that's what is
that 250 weekends is that right yeah 250
weekends that means i'm ahead of the
people around me
i'm paying the price today
in hopes that i could pay any price in
the future rule number nine follow up
follow up
all the money is in the follow-up it's
not in the meet and greet
it's not on the internet
it's in the follow-up you got a lead
somebody's interested how do i follow
them up now this is where the financial
thing comes back into play because the
follow-up is hard nobody wants to make
that second call much less the third one
or the fourth winning fifth one do you
know that 25 of all sales people make
one phone call and quit 48 never make
two calls most never make the first one
it's crazy okay most of your sales are
made closed
between the fifth and the eighth call if
you're advertising on the internet
there's a good chance you have to call
people 8 to 11 times just to get them on
the phone one time to qualify them the
first time to see if they're even on the
right product
so follow up the fortunes are in the
follow up and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
get your
taco truck i just thought we'd take a
shot at one of these obnoxious
car videos because i know you guys love
automobiles probably more than i love
them as the private jet flies over us
this is a completely obnoxious just i'm
just gonna be completely transparent for
all the haters and the naysayers and the
all of you out there that hate on people
that are successful i thought i'd give
you something to hate on today because
content is king right
[Music]
okay today we have my driver car my
driver card is what i roll in this is
the 2021 cullinan rolls-royce culinary
454 thousand dollars of nothing but
super swag obnoxious thank you bernie
marino
the next senator of ohio by the way for
this complete obnoxious beast of an
automobile okay this is not dog friendly
by the way you put a dog back here boom
that bad boy gonna be dead okay now to
my tuesday car to my tuesday car spider
458
458 what is it 488 488 i ain't got my
numbers right but i got my money right
okay 488 low rider tuesday get me ready
for hump day okay this thing is so fast
it is freaking unbelievable brings me to
my wednesday car you know what they say
about wednesday's this hump day okay
this is man this thing is nothing but
just freaking stupid luxury
stupid bentley luxury 368 000 of nothing
but obnoxious
to bring me to my washer car okay 180
000 mercedes v8 beautiful four-door
sedan when those bad boys are getting
washed i take a day off and driving the
little benz
just to keep me grateful about the
[ __ ] much
crazy stuff i got up there okay that
brings me to my friday car right do i
have a friday car yeah this is my
thursday car this is my friday ryder
this is when i go dj khaled
[Music]
we the best
this is a phantom folks this is 650 000
and nothing but beast obnoxious
freaking crazy black on black badge
but let me show you what i use on the
weekends
this
is the vehicle
that does it all for me
okay what's up man
my taco truck saturday sundays is my
taco truck this is how i paid for all
the obnoxious selling on the weekends
weekends are for the week taco trucks
are for the terrific go get you a damn
taco truck so you can buy all this
obnoxious
[Music]
bentley bling
italiano fratello
familia
culinary cuisine
grant cardone is the king and i'm
obnoxious
25 years ago
i had three friends
my life has not always been this
i had three
friends one was a drug dealer
one was my girlfriend who didn't love me
she loved the drug dealer more than she
loved me
she loved the drugs
she's still on drugs today
and my third friend
couldn't be a friend to himself much
less to me
i had three friends in my entire life
i was the black sheep of my family
five kids
everybody in my household was worried
about grant
everybody my two sisters
my brother my mother
were convinced
i would end up in prison or i would end
up dead
i should not be
here today
so at 25 i recommitted to my education
but this time i started studying not
things that were in books but people
that it actually created wealth
not people that had made money but
people that he created wealth
this is completely different i was no
longer studying accounting and economics
i was studying wealthy people and only
wealthy people i'm not talking about the
doctor that was a neighbor
that makes a million dollars a year and
he's working 18 hours a day and he hates
his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with spam i'm
talking about the yacht people i'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation i'm talking about the car
dealer that had uh 28 car dealerships or
82 car dealerships
that has indisposable money and i
quickly realized something that the
wealthy people had financial freedom and
no one else did okay a very small
percentage of people lots of people have
money my uncle had millions of dollars
he was terrified about his money
wouldn't spend it acted like a miser
buried money in the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong i
started comparing the wealthy people to
what my dad did my dad worked every day
every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard
they saved money they cut their own
grass okay
we ate all our food we turned the lights
off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow on trees a penny
saved is a penny earned eat all your
food people are starving okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that creates insecurity
and it's incorrect i don't want to talk
to you about execution and management
and business planning and
culture i want to talk to you about
money because money we believe is the
number one problem in your business
it's not mission it's not purpose it's
not all these beautiful things everybody
tells you it's not planning and
organizing i have seven businesses
there's seven little companies there's
been no plan there's been minimal
organizing
tremendous speed
tremendous speed to market okay it's one
of the things that has made us
successful but mostly
in all the businesses every business was
created
around the concept
it needs to make money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not going to be able to
call yourself a business person
[Music]
and so this industry of entrepreneurs
that that is now
so popular
i never even knew the term until like a
year and a half ago
okay before that i was in california
somebody said i was an entrepreneur
15 years ago i'm like well that's
that's code for
i don't have a job
okay today today look if you want to be
an entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money
and that provides a good living for a
lot of other people right
so number one problem in your business
is employee disengagement it is not
actually money
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see a hand
how many of you here run or manage a
household
okay good well if you can't manage the
household
by the way
you have disengagement at a household
level would you agree
husband and wife are disengaged
one's doing their own plan this one's
doing their plan 50 of those marriages
are going to fail okay that's what they
say they're going to divorce truth is
way more than 50 fail people should not
be looking at the divorce rate they
should be looking at the failure rate
first thing you got to do is decide as a
business owner do i want to make more
money see see if this dude this dude
with the camera if he shot if his if his
pockets are empty
he's walking around empty pockets
and he's got his fancy camera this is
the the problem with the artist
they starve their whole life
they starve their entire life and then
and then you wonder why they're grumpy
there's no money i'm eating at littles
all the time sooner or later
sooner or later you hit the reality he
hits the reality i got a nice camera i
love taking photos i got to shoot grant
cardone he watches lord sugar leave on
his jet
and says hey why
does he get to fly
free everywhere do whatever he wants
and i'm stuck with my camera and no
money
how many believe that
sooner or later sooner or later after
days of going to work months are going
to work years of going to work sooner or
later if he works for this man he's like
i resent this man
i resent this man i resent that man
business owner i resent paul mcfadden
the business owner i resent you so i
know i won't work for you in fact what
i'm going to do is screw things up for
you
it's called disengagement the only
business people that will survive the
only entrepreneurs that will make it in
business are those people that decide to
grow their businesses little little
will fail
not the little grocery store
okay if you try to stay small if you try
to stay small
you will fail
okay i'm telling you this from personal
experience
i tried to stay small
i tried to manage the business i tried
to be the king of the business i tried
to have no employees because employees
cost money
i'm like i'm not going to have any
employees i'm not going to pay the
camera man i'll just hire him when i do
a gig
and the next time i'll hire another guy
and that'll keep my expenses low how
many are brought up like this keep the
expenses real low where we can manage
the expenses
the expenses are going to be so small
that that no matter how much we make i
keep it all how many heard this
statement before knowledge is power
warren buffett was on tv yesterday he's
88 years old he's worth 83 billion
dollars
okay i want to know where
where the guy is in his cycle
everybody's got a life cycle
i'm young i'm broke
i get a little bit of money i'm middle
class now okay now i'm rich now i'm
super wealthy okay and now i'm gonna die
my data points will change everybody
agree with that
where are you getting the data from okay
if this is probably where i'm at right
now in a number of
places in my life both my finances my
brand recognition
uh my international presence my business
expansion i'm probably
up on a upward slope
might be down here and not even know it
yet
okay because i might not know how high i
could go
probably this is a mistake i didn't know
how big i could get
so
down here what am i telling you right
now get your money save it like if you
go back and read my books when i was 30
years old 35 years old i'm telling that
save your money save all your money save
all your money why i'm trying to put
some money away
then then i get right here i'm like i
need to get the money to work
right
i get here and i'm like i need to get
the people around me making money
when i'm starting this cycle so you need
to understand when you're listening to
me today
leave here and you go to
to john maxwell's workshop
where is john in
the cycle of his life
the source of data
steve jobs steve jobs was down here
animal he was an animal him and bill
gates were like
carnivorous
they they weren't thinking about giving
money away they didn't have any money
they were in a garage
right scrapping out man buying tacos
probably stealing a little bit
warren buffett warren buffett down here
took 500 shares of ford motor company
stock for free to pitch it
to tell people i have 500 shares of
the ipo
in 1957 ford motor company went public
he got 500 shares from the company to
say he was buying ford motor company he
didn't buy a ford motor company they
gave him the chairs it's against the law
okay he's outside the statue of
limitations that's what he did then
that's not what he's doing now look man
i've been labeled ocd acd
compulsive obsessive
cod bipolar you know they wanted to put
me on lithium prozac all this medication
okay i mean real real like serious drugs
i'm not talking about smoking weed on
the weekends and that
was supposedly to handle my energy
or my creativity or
uh the fact that i didn't like sitting
in a chair for 45 minutes at a time in
school listening to a history class of
something that happened 300 years ago
that had nothing to do with me when i'm
sitting there saying hey listen i just
want to learn how to make some money man
so you know it's finally when i quit
letting everybody all these average
people label me and said you know what
i'm going to take this obsessive
compulsive this this whatever this
energy is that that has been
you know made wrong by society i'm gonna
take this energy and i'm not gonna
suppress it anymore i'm gonna use it
so for all the kids all the kids out
there teenagers that are being
mislabeled millennials millennial's a
label man introvert is a label
lazy is a label nobody's lazy nobody is
born lazy these labels are being given
to people incorrectly and the truth is
nobody's actually lazy okay you're not
born lazy you're made lazy you're
allowed to be lazy you're encouraged to
be lazy you're surrounded by a bunch of
people that are lazy and then you become
lazy people that are being labeled ocd
add adhd i think they're geniuses it's
waiting for you there's this big gift
sitting there waiting to bubble up don't
medicate it and don't push it down give
it a voice let it be greatness and
genius rather than something bad what do
you not know about money
you need to ask yourself that what is it
you don't know about money you live on a
planet
that has endless amounts of paper
[Music]
you have plenty of sticky sticky
notepads everybody agree with that
i mean how many of you are short on
legal pads
[Music]
or our sticky notes
or ear swabs
or cotton swabs
you're not short on any of that stuff
everybody everybody has plenty of that
stuff except maybe the people in puerto
rico that by the way that's a good
example of what can happen to good
people bad things
happen to good people
and money money solves some of those bad
things from happening to them would you
agree
okay now if you didn't leave puerto rico
and you knew a cat 5 storm was coming or
irma was coming to to
to florida or harvey was coming to
houston right or you live in los angeles
and you know there's earthquakes and you
don't have a plan
what is it you don't know like like
you're not stupid you're not dumb and
you're not lazy you're a bunch of
entrepreneurs in a room
they want to do something big you would
not come to this conference if you did
not want to scale your business the
question was asked the other night why
do you want to scale you all have to
scale you have to scale for this one
reason right here you need money
you need money okay
why do i need money what don't i know
about money why are people struggling
with money you should ask yourself these
questions why are you coming up short
on money
is it what you know or what you don't
know
how many of you know this saying
knowledge is
okay how many of you agree with that
how many degree knowledge is power
so look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge
could the wrong knowledge be power
over you
right see what i'm saying so like when
you set your business up how many of you
set your business up you know about uh
uh the the average entrepreneur solo pro
makes about 42 000 bucks a year and the
average american makes 58. this guy left
the job to make less money so he could
say hey i'll work for myself me and gary
vaynerchuk had this conversation he's
like look somebody's better off making
42 for themselves than making 42 for
somebody else i said dude ain't nobody
better off making 42.
okay see this is what you need to
understand the first thing you gotta you
gotta decide now sean says he doesn't
chase a number i'm chasing a number
why would you have a target on
everything in life and not have one on
money
every athlete has a target
right every professional has a target
every department and every company every
division i have has a target
no target means what
what is your target right if i have no
target i'm successful i will hit the
zero target
a a guy's homeless out there hey begging
for food can you give me some food can
you give me some food i give him food
he's like no no no i don't really want
the food i really want dude just say it
on the sign bro
give me a hundred just change the ask
but you gotta have a target you gotta
have a target you gotta get up you gotta
get out the amount of time you spend
outside your proximity or location where
you sleep gives you a better chance of
being successful so get up get out
go meet the world head on folks no
matter how bad it is
okay you got you got reputation problems
you got
i feel bad problems
you got friend problems you got money
problems whatever the problems are
okay
try this
just get up and get out
and go meet the world head on go meet
whatever it is okay you got to make up
to somebody you got to apologize for
something you've done you got to make up
the damage of of years of neglect and
and maybe uh betrayal and look i've done
all that i've had all those things where
i screwed up over and over and over
again my reputation sucked
i was 20 between the ages of 15 and 25
years old
it was like i was doing everything i
could just to damage
damage my reputation okay if it made me
look bad i did it
so here today i'm gonna spend 10 days 14
days something like that up here with
that view
you can fix anything i'm proof that you
can fix anything anything
can be fixed
anything can be fixed but you got to fix
it
you got to fix it you can't just
sweep it under the old rug
you got to fix it you got to clean up
the damage you got to pay the price
clean up your debts
do what you say you're going to do
become the most dependable person
in your space become the go-to person
oh i can put that person on stage and
know exactly what they're gonna get for
me i can put that person in the game and
i know what play they're gonna run i can
put that person on the floor and i know
they're gonna get it done be the go-to
person
okay you don't need to be funny
you don't need to be entertaining all
the time
you don't need to be the person you're
talking about you need to be the go-to
person folks the thing that i do at my
company
that is very unusual is that we are
completely unreasonable
without reason without we don't use
yes i'm logical okay yes i'm a sane
person but when it comes to achieving a
target
we we do it with like we abandon
reason and logic we don't talk about
yeah but we never start yeah but or no
we can't or we couldn't because or it
didn't happen because any anytime you're
talking anytime you're making sense of
why something didn't work we don't have
the budget we can't do that because yeah
but we're different you are being
reasonable
the great things that have happened on
this planet and continue to happen are
because people are unreasonable
they literally abandon reason and logic
they defy the universe now if you look
around if you're a logical person if
you're a person who has to make sense of
it beforehand then spend some time
looking around the universe look at
nature look at all the things that are
done every day
that literally defy gravity defy
possibility defy physics it's all over
the place if you need to be reasonable
now in my case i don't need to be
reasonable
because there's enough
cases of super successful people doing
things that are amazing whether it was a
manufacturing a new product
or whether it was steve jobs
coming back to apple and turning that
company around every day every look at
amazon look what amazon has done
okay now you look at it you're like dude
that's a no-brainer
make every make all products available
online
now it's a no-brainer now it's like it's
so logical look at velcro
velcro was like god i i should have
thought of that see but beforehand it
was completely out of reason that you
could stick
things together
uh because they scratch one another you
understand what i'm saying so look this
is what i want you to try try this in
your life it's gonna be very difficult
it's one of the most difficult things i
do is being unreasonable because all the
people i'm surrounded by are trying to
make sense of why they can't do
something quit making sense of why you
can't do something and become
unreasonable until you do do something
i've been lost most of my life literally
the first 45 years of my life
the first probably 51 years of my life
first 45 years for sure i was completely
lost
and uh somewhere between 45 and 51 i
started figuring out okay what am i
doing i started sorting my life out i
started getting some started doing some
courses that really really made a
difference in my life i've always been
in a self-improvement my whole life
and
but it wasn't until i was about 45 that
i really started discovering
information that could make me more
confident me more sure
you know when i was 25 years old i was a
young sales person and i didn't like
sales and and i got educated on how to
sell and i became very very good at it
um i started understanding the process
the customer the objections the
rebuttals how to follow up how to handle
the rejection and the disappointment to
discourage how to get over it but that
didn't help me become
more confident in me as a person as an
individual i was making money
by the time i was 31 i had a couple
businesses
they were making money probably had
you know
three four hundred thousand dollars
saved when i was 30 31 years old because
i was trying to make a little money
right by the time i'm 33 i got a
probably a million dollars in a bank i
still didn't feel good about myself
i had this nagging nagging like
sense of desperation anxieties
depression
uncertainty a lack of confidence
and
when i started working on me spiritually
that's that's when that's when at 45 46
47 years old that's when everything
changed for me
like everything all the expansion the
confidence the getting out in the world
uh maybe a little better communicating
than i was doing i'm not perfect at it
by any means now
and i started getting more certainty
about who i am what i am where i'm going
and why i'm here like if you don't
figure those things out no amount of
money no amount of money in the world
will
will fill you up no
the private planes won't the fancy cars
you have to know where you're going your
parents were looking for 40 grand
it doesn't pay for anything today
so you need to change the way you think
how many of you were taught when you ate
when mama brought you a meal she said
this she brought you the meal threw it
on the plate and said eat it all how
many were told that you know what she
was trying to tell you
don't waste money that's what she was
trying to say what she was really saying
is i don't know how to make more money
she was really saying there's a shortage
of money eat it all there's people in
china starving
how many of you got that message every
day how many of you when you walked out
of your bedroom your mama said turn off
those lights
what was she telling you
i don't know how to get new money
that's what she was telling you my dad
died when i was 10 my mom was left to
bring up five kids okay and those are
the messages i got every day
the same message was this contract
get small back up protect yourself
i can't win anything like this
i cannot succeed for my family like this
i do not want my kids to see me like
this
i want i want my kids to see me on
attack
right confidence in the marketplace how
do you get confidence you read man you
guys gotta read okay the at the average
american reads less than one book a year
half those books are romance novels
now i don't have my books with me today
but we i've written four books since
2009 for this new economy i wrote those
books for me i didn't write them for
other people i did not write them to get
known i wrote those books because i was
trying to figure out how do i get myself
out of this problem i'm going to save
money this is what you hear if you look
on the internet how do i make money
first thing you got to do is you got to
save money
what do you hear the politicians say the
middle class i'm here to save it
what if there is no middle class and it
was just made up
to keep the people civil
see
see that that's how you're going to play
this game you got to be available people
have to know you
don't talk to strangers strangers got
everything you want man
everything you want a stranger's got it
[ __ ] your friends ain't got nothing
right
if it's up to your friends you're done
you're like oh my friends are broke i'm
25 years old everybody around me was
broke okay
my mama was scared every time my mama
tuesday tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was the reason to get the newspaper
the coupons are coming
she would sit there and clip a man she
had him in the little box i learned that
for for 16 years i watched my mom do
that for 16 years my mom would tell me
hey grant turn those lights off turn
those lights off me and my twin brother
turn those lights off from across the
house she could hear me walk out of my
bedroom 75 feet away and say hey turn
those damn lights off
i told you okay twin brothers okay i'm
16 years old my twin brother my mom said
when you guys go pee
do it together
saves water
saves water right okay when my mom fed
me because mama i had a great mom how
many of you had great parents
give you give your parents a great hand
huh
hey
just because they were great parents
doesn't mean they weren't confused
right because my mama was confused man
my mom did not know how to make money
she had no education she had no ability
she had never held a job she did not
know how to get money so what she had to
do was protect the little bit of money
she had sell or be sold she was sold on
conservation
reduce risk don't spend contract protect
it defend it
you understand diversify
have a lot of little bets all over the
place okay
lots of little bets you should never
have a lot of bets all over the place
until you're extremely wealthy
when you're trying to get wealthy you
want to literally you want to go all in
and it not be a vet you need to know the
space so well
that you're like i know for sure this is
going to work what do you know will pay
you every time
for sure
you everybody's trying to go out there
and not sell you guys are all trying to
like i i'm gonna i'm gonna be talented
talent does not win
i know a whole bunch of guys less
talented than me that beat me for years
they beat me because they got exposure
in the marketplace some of those names
just in different sectors okay in real
estate okay i got a there's a group that
they went out and bought 140 000 units
um
you know i got for 4 500. they're not as
good
they they make take a lot of shortcuts
they don't take care of the tenant as
well as i do but they thought way bigger
than i did
so um
you know what i'm saying like it's in
different spaces there was an automotive
space that i was in for years i was the
leader in the automotive space me and
another guy constantly combating
right
he had a garbage product
he sold for less than i did
he
he scaled better than i did he beat me
at the scale game so you can't see a lot
of people say look look man steve jobs
started his business in a garage
uh the the i think cadillac's got a
commercial where the cadillac was
created in a garage
who else bill gates started his business
in a garage
mark zuckerberg started facebook in a
dorm
everybody's like oh my god man i can do
this from home none of those companies
got big
when they stayed in the garage in the
dorm
markey z didn't make it until he moved
to silicon valley and built a team okay
google didn't become google until they
had a campus in silicon valley and they
scale to tens of thousands of employees
so you have to scale to be great so
would you say then for the average
entrepreneur out there as they are as
they're growing their business getting
those sales they should definitely be
setting some of that income aside you
should you should be source yeah you
should not be thinking about what you
can live on
right i made eight grand this month man
all of its net profit
all that money should be reinvested in
people
so that that's why people think
incorrectly that's why i always go back
to this argument about look the
solopreneurs are selfish
almost like a little selfish child
right
i'm gonna go out i left my job i was
making 90 grand now i'm gonna me and
gary vaynerchuk had this conversation i
was making 90 grand now i'm going to
work for myself and make 90 grand and
gary's like well yeah the guy's better
off the guy's better off working for
himself for 90 grand than working for
somebody else and i'm like dude nobody's
better off working for 90 grand you
can't live on 90 grand not today you
can't no anywhere in america there's
nowhere in america you live in for 90
grand in miami you're going to have
twelve thousand dollars before taxes
left over at the end of the year if you
don't shop at whole foods so the the
point of that is if you were working for
90 000 for a company and then you go
work for yourself for 90 000
you should be taking that money and
buying a secretary buying a receptionist
buying scale buying a sales team
reinvesting money you should not have
any money left over at 90 grand all of
it should be going to be poured back
into the business to scale out unless
all you're thinking about is yourself
right i grew up in lake charles
louisiana for those of you don't know my
story and my dad uh my dad was
uh
he had
five kids wife he was dedicated and
committed to being the provider for his
family like many of you are how many of
you provide for your family
probably want to do a good job at it my
dad wanted to do a good job at it so my
dad died when i was 10 years old he had
he had owned a
life insurance company he actually
started a life insurance company
it was taken from his him and a partner
it was taken from him at the age of uh i
guess he was 42 years old
42 years old he's got five kids
he's got a wife to take care of and no
job how many have been in transition
before
yeah so 42 a lot of obligation now
starting to move into the middle class
42 years old he's got he's got twin boys
coming they didn't plan us
you know good catholic family
doing the planning every five years we
had they'd have a baby so he was playing
you could tell like like when i look
back in my in his life today there's a
long answer to a short question but
like like you guys you guys need to
figure out your your why you're gonna do
whatever you're gonna do
my dad knew why he was going to do what
he was going to do but my dad didn't
think big enough
it's it's it's it's a it's a uh i i got
two things for my dad one every day he
worked he was up early he stayed late
he's in transition between 42 and 52.
he's in transition in his life right
he's having to go from
life insurance company big dream company
gets stolen away from him he's like what
am i doing
right this is the story of the middle
class right here this is called gravity
this is uh yesterday's miami bridge
falling
and everybody's like i can't believe
that happened
structures fall folks
so this is what i learned from my dad my
mom had to sell a dream house that was
paid for in cash my dad bought a dream
house a year and a half before he bought
before he died
we all went in celebrated oh my god this
is unbelievable this is crazy this is
great we made it to the middle class my
dad dies my mom has to sell the house a
week
literally a week after my dad dies
when she should have been grieving she
was having to sell this dream house
you understand what i'm saying this is
what i learned when i was 10 years old
man life is short
okay my dad didn't provide he did he
worked hard but he didn't have enough
because if he had enough my mom would
not have had to sell the dream house
anybody agree with that
okay my mom did not know how to produce
new income so my mom had to go into
conservation
so when you asked me the question how
did you start i started with the wrong
data
okay i started with the wrong data and
the data was hey life is short something
bad is going to happen all that's true
but if you could out produce
if you could produce enough income you
could start solving some of these
problems like indestructible income five
grand is a doable deal how do i do it
it's 412 dollars a month
okay i gotta go steal the money i can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and i wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add five thousand of that
and earn twenty percent it'd be worth a
million one twenty five if you can do
this at ten and be worth 320. some of
you small thinkers out there be like
dude i'll take the 320. how do i get 10
and how do i get 20. you guys have
figured this out you're like
if the play is big enough dude i'll
figure that out everybody agree see what
i just i shifted your mind by giving you
a target
i don't go to target i get targets and i
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is i want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
i got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20
a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy gc
got rich
i didn't get rich speaking i didn't get
rich selling books
i got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all i did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when i was not watch this
even when i was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand
boom guess what next year oh by the way
this money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy account
holy means okay i'm gonna put a hole in
your face if you touch my money
nobody could get this money this is a
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man i could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29 what am i
doing right here okay
one two three four boom i got twenty
five thousand dollars sitting in an
account
it wasn't a million dollars and i'm five
years into the plan
but when i was ready to start investing
money i started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32. i'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
charters showing off going on vacations
all i'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens i have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know i had twenty five thousand dollars
to add to my twenty five thousand
dollars next year i'm making more money
i got twenty five thousand dollars you
see what i'm doing i'm stacking dough
and looking
for 20
i know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to one million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay
your job is to find a vehicle that can
pay you 20 a year might be a business
might be the business you're in it might
be to buy advertising for the business
or brand urine for me it was this i'm
gonna buy real estate
that over long periods of time
i will earn cash flow okay that's how
the real estate works
i put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
you said yeah but grant you said what'd
you say grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah i
know what i said
this ain't eddie okay now how much do i
have i could reinvest that money back in
the deal the next year i have 27
500
i earned 10 on that
that's 27.50 or something like that
i reinvest that now i got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as i own it over
20 years
2038 we'll dispose of this thing the
rent is going up as i'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 percent a year
[Music]
by the time i sell i want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
a year
[Music]
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that
for long periods of time the trick is
long periods of time i'm 19 years old
and i run a consulting firm
and uh right now i just tell you real
estate stuff and i have only about 60
grand from what i've done saved up yeah
and do you think i need to still wait
until 100 grand if you pass the real
estate or yeah
how long you had 60 grand uh for just
like 12 months now yeah dude like you
got to get the other 40 bro
it's an arbitrary number i just made up
the number it could be 110 it could be
dude it's just it's just so you know
first of all when you get to 100 call me
and i'm gonna probably tell you hey man
you need to wait till you got 350.
but at least then you're gonna be like
you know what i learned how to make i
learned how to not just make 100 save
100 and put 100 away
people are investing too soon you guys
are investing three grand here two grand
over here a thousand bucks 500 you're
walking away from it it's never worth
any money it's dumb
and you never create the discipline what
you end up with is a bunch of losses a
bunch of little losses
rather than knowing i have the
confidence that i can make money set it
aside protect it
right protect it like a kid
[Music]
right
it's not going to get in a wreck i don't
lose it
i would do that first
so was there an age i didn't invest my
my first investment was five thousand
dollars and i blew it
and i'm like i'm not doing that again my
next investment is going to be big where
i'm gonna watch it
because if it's big enough dude if your
life depends on it you'll get up in the
mornings and you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 grand it took
three years to do it all i did was save
money save money save money i put 350
grand in the deal sold that deal for
four million dollars a four million
dollar profit but every last penny you
had i had i had one third of all my
money in that deal i had a million
dollars like a million one
put 350 in my first deal 30 days later
put 450 in a second deal 90 days later
put all the rest of my capital 100 of
all my money
plus 90 grand
in three real estate deals
those are the first three investments i
ever made my the first three or four
investments i made in my entire life
three of the four did the little one
didn't
[Music]
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
what's it going to do
it's not going to do anything
it's like going into a casino and you
bet 15
right you get blackjack
so what it's still 15
the first thing you're going to say is
dude i should have bet everything
but you didn't
shouldn't even be in there look buying a
jet was something i never dreamed i'd do
i never okay i only started thinking
about it four or five years ago when i'm
young and broke i'm growing up in
louisiana middle class being told be
grateful you gotta bite on a bike be
grateful you got clothes on your back
and you get three meals be grateful for
all that you got cause you got it better
than i do i never dreamed of having my
own damn checks
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning hot you do it you borrow
money okay use money if it requires
money so be it if you're truly obsessed
it will be worth it because you will get
the results you know the secret to
sustaining the obsession is a
straightforward one focus your efforts
on everything that will fuel you for the
long run and ignore eliminate and block
out anything that drains you or causes
you doubt
money power fame success all all of them
follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow the problem with these things
is money power fame and success even
time off they they require attention
they're like jealous lovers they need
constant attention or they're gonna
leave you how you invest your time is
more important than how you invest your
money being obsessed with your sense of
purpose across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish all the
things you desire i think most people
are not accomplishing what they want in
one area of life because they quit on
all the other ones if you quit on all
the other ones how are you going to get
this one to run nothing inspires me more
than surrounding myself with people who
have achieved more than i have and then
meeting new people i need the obsessed
must surround themselves with people you
trust and respect who think big who've
done bigger than you and who can help
you get to where you want to go you
think you can run only so fast
time is no longer an excuse because the
obsessed
make time they don't make excuses you
guys would take days off it's my day off
you ain't entitled to a day off
[Music]
why do you think you should have
wednesdays off or thursdays or or you
can't work saturdays or
sunday sunday you can't work on a sunday
okay are you and you got people around
you telling you not to work on sunday we
have to have a little life balance dude
how can you have life balance when you
broke
how can you have life balance at a
holiday inn when the people next door
keep you up all night
that ain't life balance that's not even
a vacation
right the whole trip how many been on
the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast
you did it on miles
and you wish you didn't even go how many
been on that trip before
maybe you don't do the trip maybe you're
not entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready to trip
that's what elena and i did for 10 years
the sacrifice the sacrifice today we'll
sacrifice this week we'll sacrifice this
month we'll sacrifice this year we'll
sacrifice
so one day maybe we don't have to
compromise every week we talk about our
finances what do we do this week how
much do we make where are we going what
are we spending okay the moment i say
hey no more jackets no more [ __ ]
stop it she'll stop it
so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there
there is should come a time where you
guys should be able to spend whatever
you want but most people are spending
what they can afford
now only to find out later they can
never have anything they don't
understand how to make their money
multiply and most people don't
understand there is a sacrifice phase we
went through the sacrifice phase where
there was years of just cut off
everything and we weren't saving for a
landing
for the rainbow that's right y'all need
to save for the rainbow you need to you
see we didn't go on a vacation for 13
years
yeah i've been saving for this stuff
i wasn't saving for vacations i was
saving so i could bank into real estate
so i could go to sleep at night
and even if i had a bad night of sleep
and had to get up three or four times
i'm like dang i'm making money in my
sleep even if i'm unhappy i'm like i'm
making money in my sleep man see that's
the goal that you and your wife need to
have let's make money when we go to
turks and caicos or when we go to st
bart's or when we go to cali let's go
waste some money later in our life maybe
you say hey i'm going to sacrifice
today
so i don't have to compromise in the
future when i was 23 years old i was
beaten within
inches of my life i had 76 stitches put
in my head and face because i had made
nine years of bad choices
my dad died when i was 10 years old
i think that there's an epidemic in this
country where where families
are missing a father
i know for me i was a good kid i i grew
up in a middle class family my mom and
my dad were very responsible hard
working people
i didn't get beat up there was no
alcoholism there was no drug addiction i
did not get brought up the way kanye
west did
kanye's got excuses i didn't have any
and there's a whole bunch of kids in
america that don't have any excuses but
they don't have
a purpose they don't have an opportunity
and they don't have anything to do
and that was me
when my dad died i was 10 years old and
from 10 to 16 when i should have been
experiencing grief
you know and and and
i was angry about it how many of you had
a loss before and you got angry about it
customer doesn't buy from you guy
doesn't show up you get angry
angry is not a response to the
situation then when somebody sits on
anger for long enough what happens is
without a purpose without a purpose an
individual is going to go away
no matter how good they are they're
going to go off and do other things
and so by the time i was 16 years old i
had a drug problem but by the time i was
20 years old i was using drugs every
single day and by the time i was 23 i
was carrying a gun
every day
worried i was going to get killed every
day had a college degree 17 years of
spending school the more mo the more
college i got the less money i had and
the more trouble i ended up in
okay 23 years old i get beat i'm in a
hospital my mom comes to the hospital
she looks at me and says but where's my
son
okay that was me not too long ago it
doesn't seem like it was that long ago
and today legalshield has me to speak to
you today
okay
i i tell you that to tell you like
anybody can come back i don't care how
old you are how young you are what color
you are what your problems are anybody
can come back is saying hey man if
you've got a million dollars you're
basically just a freaking deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income
and you were
how old are you
you're 27 years old i'm gonna do this at
47 i'm gonna do it at uh at
65.
27 you don't have any more income how
long will that money last
at 4 000 a month
you got 25 years where can you live
on 4 000 a month you'd have to live on
four thousand dollars a month for 25
years you will be 52 years old my friend
and dead broke
number one thing you got to do is this
you got to change the target and you
need to look at the target daily the
target you have the wrong target right
now if you're struggling you have the
wrong target
when you change the target everything
changes
now and i started with zero just so you
guys know i didn't have anything okay so
look it's simple target what's your new
target freedom
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it
your first target should be 10 million
and nothing short of that number one the
target number two you need to get your
income to a place this is a fascinating
concept right here
okay if you can do this i guarantee
you'll be rich
you need to get your income not to what
pays your bills but to where you can
save 40
of your gross income
is saved
all right so now now when you do this
math you're like dude how much money do
i actually need let's kick this up to 20
grand at 20 grand what happens
you're saving eight
storage
you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget
you make 30 000
12 is going to storage
12 is going to the ir and the s
and that leaves you with six
so now you can start seeing do you got
to be somewhere north of 300 grand a
year this is what they don't teach you
at harvard
you got to be somewhere north to 360 a
year before you even have money to live
on unless you're just
you know you're direct
[Music]
you're just an irresponsible human being
that that's
you know not putting storing money away
for the future
okay now you're saving 12 grand a month
that's 144 000 in one year in 10 years
that's 1.4 million dollars in 10 years
you're a millionaire stored
you guys need to be heavily money
motivated from a survival standpoint
okay number three thing you're gonna do
you're gonna go broke right here
and invest
the storage
storage has to get invested
the golden goose is only good if she
lays eggs
otherwise you can kill her eat her for a
chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies
right so your goal right here is to
invest to invest the storage money
and continue to do that until this money
over here the passive money
is equal
to
your income
[Music]
right so what would i do i'd go out i'm
gonna make 30 grand i'm going to store
12 i'm gonna pay the irs i'm gonna live
on six warren buffett says don't lose
money number one number two don't lose
money
i would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what peter field was
saying
a single digit millionaire cannot even
provide themselves with their own
personal
defense in america
okay hulk hogan all that money hulk
hogan made he blew it all
he blew it all probably buying hair
pieces
okay he blew it all he blew it all ended
up with a little money thought he was
the [ __ ] oh man i got a little money
until he had that freaking lawsuit and
then he can't even defend himself
so it happens to a lot of people how
many how many of you know a family
member lost their job
okay how many of you have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to to rehab for
30 days and it costs 40 grand
that happens how many of you know
somebody got cancer
okay how many know somebody in a car
accident cost three or four hundred
grand
what
happens the problem is not that [ __ ]
happens it happens and people aren't
ready for it oh god i can't believe this
happened to me oh [ __ ] really
goddamn you've been around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
you live on a planet with water
i'm just saying you might want to get a
swimming lesson
it's a wet planet yeah you got it you
got it you got every everywhere you go
you need you need to confront every time
you hit up against oh the the room's 249
the the mill is 25 bucks uh starbucks is
six dollars the airline flight costs 600
every time you like oh
okay you need to understand that you're
being reminded you don't have enough
money
it has nothing to do with the price
but but watch how much people
disassociate
oh american airlines is charging too
much for that ticket
that has nothing to do with it you don't
you don't make enough money
okay so i had a guy i was in oakland
california i was flying back and i said
uh hey anybody want to fly home with me
and the guy's like i want to fly home
with you i'll do it i said good i'll be
48 thousand dollars for fuel oh oh i
don't want to do it
no you can't do it because you don't
have the money
fuel's not the problem he didn't he
doesn't make enough money so just start
flipping things so like now when i see
wagyu remember that wagoo we ate in
vegas it was like 115 for a strip that
big
never do it again by the way
but the fact that i complain about it
only means
i don't make enough money
and if the wagu's too much money
if the 115 for a little strip of wagyu
is too much money
what does that say about what i'm
selling my products for
not charging them up can't get enough i
have this idea so it's really to me it's
really
we go to paris man and we go to the
chanel store and there's people in line
in line out the front door at the chanel
store i'm like oh my god great
experience for me how much money is on
this planet go to monaco see the yachts
200 million 240 300 million dollars 300
millions they cost 30 million a year to
take care of them
great experience
flying private been a great experience
for me
okay guy has five jets not not he's not
complaining about a first class seat
anymore and the peanuts
he's got five jets
different level man all of a sudden you
start thinking different start asking
different
start working deals different
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one i did
recently with grant check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created investing
elon musk is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses